with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see how
serverless helps you build secure
scalable apps then stay tuned because
here's the rewind when you're building a
cloud application security is always on
your mind
it takes a constant effort to stay ahead
of the threat vectors which can easily
burn up engineering time thankfully
server lists offerings can help cut down
the amount of effort you need
vulnerabilities can exist in almost
every stage of your tech stack
starting with hardware all the way up to
your application code with server lists
everything below your application code
is managed by Google without any actions
needed on your part while you're still
responsible for the security of your
code GCP has a few tools to help make it
a little easier on you first cloud
functions has just released support for
max instances configuration which allow
you to reduce your vulnerability to both
denial of service attacks as well as a
hug of death where you might
inadvertently do s your own backends
without knowing it
there's also improved budgets and budget
alerts which can help prevent against do
s attacks designed exhauster resources
next cloud functions has just rolled out
support for environment variables so
instead of leaking credentials by
putting them directly in your code you
can manage them from a separate console
interface and finally new I am controls
grant the ability to specify which users
have access to run and interface with
what cloud functions meaning you can
create micro surfaces which instead of
being available to the outside world by
default can be limited to only interact
with other systems inside your
application now this is just a sampling
from the main talk if you're interested
in a larger list of vulnerabilities as
well as some great demos from NPM and
intrinsic check out the full talk linked
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]